aber ich habe keine zeit die pit mine
horne das hat nicht das hat auf alle
fälle nicht gar hier reicht das essen
haben wir noch mehr
auf gar keinen fall genau das ist ja ok
oh nein nein nein ich hab jetzt
vielleicht doch mal die finger gehauen
was servus s kids und auch an alle
zuschauer von oben herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge um minecraft legend
mit
die gerne gehen drauf ist und zwar auf
das sind nord felsen
connecting heimatlos nein von action
short story connecting das was machst du
hey was soll da anmelden anmeldet und
darauf unser heutiger plan ist es
lustigs gesetzt in den keller zu gehen
wir starten heute in der
rüstung schau mal kurz wenn die items
über die macht
ja aber gegen die höhe hätte es noch da
gucken können oder aber wir haben aber
nicht so viel dass man das von
weiterbilden mündern wäre ich dafür
zumindestens dass man den sport noch
durchsuchen da wird sich irgendwo noch
enger und dann gleich wieder gehen
haben wir auch wieder in die kommentare
geschrieben könne den frauen da gibt es
essen ohne ende er war nämlich ein
ganzes strohlager das jetzt weg
hier oben wo man heute schon hier ist
auch obsidian also ja nee das vom portal
das also einmal einmal schmuck durch
und so muss man immer gucken welche
namen sehen noch jemand davor einem
lover platziert scheinbar
ja
gerade jetzt da liebe spannend aber
lasst einfach eine aufgabe nicht mehr so
viel
vorher etwas explodiert und dann hast du
noch viel ja ein brot deswegen wollte
ich ja erstmal jetzt noch ein bisschen
nach essen besuchen wo bist du dann lass
mal wieder beieinander bleiben konnte
wieder mal hier sind habe ich irgendwas
zum brennen obwohl das gold das in gold
platten darauf kann man da
bist du dann raus ich werde hier ist
cool geworden ist und in welchem haus
ihr in so einem haus jona portalhaus
oder net wat ich komme nach hause kommt
noch hausherr ist kohle rufen die kann
man noch mitnehmen wollen hier kann man
mit hallo hier vorne wenn ich komme ja
ich kann man aus latten irgendwas zurück
und dann bin ich hier bin ich hier hoch
und dann mal hier sind die escola in dem
ofen ja auch mal wieder was das hier
sind kräftig federn lassen dann lasst
die kohle mitnehmen beziehungsweise
watte gepackt nicht noch mal rein und
ich brauche noch mal schnell das fleisch
was ich hier habe man auch erst mal ein
bisschen
was überlegen aber uns ist nur die kiste
rhein wo neue materialien drin
lol was das mal die andere kisten haben
körper da oben drüber ist
lästig
wir brauchen wir waren träge meine also
gute väter kann man das eventuell
beschreiben ne es noch nicht aber auch
nicht übrig für die rüstung ja hier ist
doch ich nehme an dass wichtige mit was
man mitnehmen kann ok dann lasst aber
dann auch
was vom himmel runter starten auch wenn
man die jukebox mitnehmen
warum auch immer geil zahl die junge der
körper bei disco pogo nein ich kann ihn
nicht mitnehmen ich mache mal kurz näher
kann man aber irgendwie team seine basis
kann man doch nicht aufstecken das erste
mal dass wir boden auf weißen alter ohne
scheiß jetzt ich glaube da ist was ich
glaube einfach hier kommt man bieten
jedes hauses sondern stärke hier wird
nichts ein wo könnte man hier noch was
verstecken könnte man hier sind die
ersten kisten ganz normale
da oben kisten normale standard kisten
aber sind dann las ich in den level
gelassen den bergen kommt ja okay wir
machen sich nehme ich nehme am rand noch
ein bisschen holz mit aber brauchen ein
bisschen gebraucht wirst du woher
kriegen also ja ich nehme auch ein
bisschen holz für richtige was not kann
man rotten flesh mehr
anbrennen hast du zufällig ein gold
bei euch ein bisschen dass mich mal
wieder
weiter weiter weiter weiter ich muss
kurz durch seit ihrem 8 x 8 x 8 x 8 x
mach mal eine neue werk bank brauche ich
noch regen lassen überall anlass aber
heute ihre rüstung machen ja scheiße ich
bin aus dem haus gefühl ich komme
ja ich weiß gar nicht ob man den stones
und demolieren egal war der wachleute
extra wiederholt dass in kisten aber wo
ist das kleine kiste dass das heute hier
ist der glaube du bist du gehst du
siehst du das ja das ist ja dann weiß
ich bin schon wieder runter gefallen
menschen der warte ich gehe noch mal
hoch aber macht und macht davon hier
aber was würde würde ich bleibe ja ja
ich halte ihn mal ausschau
ach da ist noch kohle hattest du nicht
mitgenommen heute war erst dann ist das
unter dem snap hier ja irgendwo
hauptperson ok ausrüstung jetzt eine
feuerkugel redstone reisen spitzhacke
dann was zu essen damit buch eisenerz
erweisen als mitnehmen wir mit habe ich
mit knochen mehr nehme ich mal mit im
boot eine feuerkugel war vollkugel da
kann man eigentlich quasi und dann was
rein aber auch später fünf minuten lasst
doch erstmal lassen wenn das unter der
ecke war wo kann man da kann man dann
unter den unter den decken eventuell
noch was verstecken oder können schauer
in der anderen ecke keine ahnung was da
würde ich gerade mal den boden noch oft
unter der zweiten ecke war noch eine
kiste hey du bist so ein fucking
sherlock junge die kommission gut
so
carola bist hast du dir jemand zum
entspannten braucht wohl aber der server
ist nicht auf der 1.8 oder
weiß ich nicht mit mir nicht so hast du
da haben auch die kohle kohle den
rechten rand in den in den rechten ja da
dass wir uns so schnell und
ich mache ich meine worte die wir mit
kann man gebrauchen
rotten flesh nehmen womit das kann man
auch gebrauchen wenn es wirklich mal
ganz not am mann ist wie viel knochen
gehen haben wir wir könnten ja ich hab
da einiges an doch noch gefunden wir
könnten nämlich theoretischen weizenfeld
an pflanzen und bis dann direkt abwerten
was ja aber gut jetzt haben auch für den
fall der fälle erst mal
das ding jetzt gehen wir da kommt ja ja
ich schreibe gerade noch was wer auch
immer die kiste hier passiert und wenn
er zurückkommt wir das schöne schild
lesen ist schreib in israel lobby haben
jetzt auch das andere weil ich beide
staaten müssen rec rec
die
das team wie auch immer geholt haben
habe ich hab kein essen weiter aus dass
die wir da drin hast du die kohle
mitgenommen nicola
meinungsforscher kollege
mario klotz upgrade in den wald wo es
langgeht sagen
daraus ja okay dann läuten aber den
krieg und lagen damit über rund 9 wo
kann so groß also da ist krieg packard
auf der anderen seite runter gefallen
egal was daraus gemacht da raus gehen
lassen wir sollten weg aus der stadt weg
vom
space und ob dies in der vierten folge
wir können gehen die kämpfen da kommt
schnell näher so schnell schnell schnell
schnell die kinder mussten folgten gegen
uns im na warte
ich immer schön warm und weise wie diese
sind dann haben ein problem wenn jetzt
mehrere
monate nicht okay dürfen wir das portal
zu bauen so dass wird es länger brauchen
um rauszukommen dürfen wir nicht anders
flächen in dieser feste
dann guck mal da wurde was einem da
wurden schon eingebaut ist ja ich das
dann guck mal schöne gestaltung wenn die
items was wir brauchen für die rüstung
schnell
mit mit womit wir brauchen und was
wollen wir in rüstung machen
wir brauchen mehr leser ziegel und
kloster und ein kloster habe ich
übrigens aus dieser kiste die wir
gefunden damit genommen kloster und aber
groß sondern
bloß tun würde also für zwei brustpanzer
erreichen ok brauchen wir auch noch
netter kurz ist glaube ich rekord war
ich gleich nach was du musst mich aber
dann beschützen halt wegen und ich
gleich nach ich kann gleich nicht mehr
rein passt auf
lang man habe extra kräften tape für die
hölle gemacht da die truppen dann kann
man ihn nicht zurück kräften notfalls
ist mir einfach dass man flash auch
scheißegal euro gab es auch durch die
prignitz
wir hatten nicht gleich gebaut haben ich
dachte
ja gar nicht so ein vogel die pigmente
noch nicht oder des handels sei er so
aggressiv auf mich zugerannt ist ich
schwöre es das kann nicht sein die werde
das argument es sei denn die haben die
akkus von irgend ein anlass genommen die
gehauen hat es kann auch sagen aber dass
man hingehen aber wenn jetzt man auf uns
zu ändern müssen flüchten aber wie
kriegt macht gerade den todeskampf gegen
den gas- und ich weg nicht mehr war ich
kein essen mehr warte warte warte warte
pickt man das ist nämlich so wenn die
arbeiten ziehen dann dann geschieht ist
einem gigantischen umkreis watte
probleme vielleicht zu essen guck mir
dass reinhardt weiter warten müssen also
was brauchen wir jetzt noch ne fabrik
oder
und aber sonst nichts mehr brauchen wir
gucken alle parts durch
inventar ohnehin wird nicht escape
inventar für den für den bus tag
brauchen wir ja auch mal quad seile wir
brauchen also auch ein ganzes stückchen
ein quarz okay also hast du eine
spitzhacke dabei ja habe ich war auch
ein waren noch welche in der kiste dann
gehen wir mit aber ich habe keine zahl
die pit mine horne das hat nicht das hat
auf alle fälle nicht gereicht dass es da
noch mehr
auf gar keinen fall die pigmente okay
wir müssen auch gucken ich sehe also
wenn euch die helden vom raum mal ab ob
die villinger aber vorsichtig ja ihr
braucht man nämlich und über brauchen
wir doch bloß los angeles dann brauchen
wir nicht noch mehr lebst und laptop wir
sind erstmal befreit wie viel zeit haben
wir denn wir haben noch
fünf minuten glaube ich perfekt wir
haben das mal mehr weg wir brauchen ja
ich nehme einfach mal 20 oder somit also
irgendwie nach außen noch kurz gehalten
aber kurz danach quartz aber bei
quarzkristall ich baue das hier mal
nicht dass da jetzt gleich noch einer
von wenigen des jackpots
das müssen wir das wollen wir hier noch
wegen lohnen gucken oder ist das zu
riskant es sowas kann dass man mit dass
wir das machen wir über rüstung haben
okay erwarten wir eher 31 ziegel reicht
jetzt auch wir nur noch kloster
und
die nennt sich das gute stück quarz dem
kloster ist das kleine stückchen könnte
also ich weiß nicht wie viel genau für
quad sollen braucht aber dass es gibt
auch ein gutes guten level sich aber
riesig kannst mir auch eine spitzhacke
trocken ja da da ist noch eine alt da
macht die sache so spitzhacken zusammen
dürfte noch eine weile halten und habe
jetzt wieder eingesammelt da heute da
ich habe daher heute geschmissen und
einmal den rand da bitteschön und eine
liegt da unten vor der wand oder habe
ich etwas was kann ich jetzt weg werfen
opel soll aber nicht dass kovats das
chaos perfekt mehr kleine stückchen
quartz bräuchte man noch leuchtet auch
noch eine fixe mehmet ekici
gedanken denke mir nach
dem abitur in gefallen war nie wieder
krieg das
war so ein kleiner zurück - und ich
wusste gar nicht dass sie gibt sind aber
gleich da war in santa cruz auf mich
aber hat er nicht gehauen aber ich
schwöre der ist so richtig aggressiv auf
mich zugerannt hat mich angeguckt mit
diesen türsteher blick der so hart und
kompromisslos team ist neu hinten an so
einer soll ich bin erst kurz ab
so aber habe ich hier oben ein bisschen
dabei kurz für eine war kurz natürlich
auch sensationell gut um erfahrung zu
fahren ja aber die spitzhacke geht so
schnell kaputt vom never quite ja an
einen sachten geht es sehr schnell
kaputt
okay ich habe jetzt
17 mal kurz gucken du brauchst für einen
quartz blog brauchst du 400 kurz und ich
werde für eine quad säule brauchst du
viel wasser schauen wir noch
für eine quartz für zwei quads brauchst
du zwei also pharma noch sagen wir mal
10 stück und wir kommen ich habe 15
wo dort ist aber hoch wär doch mal kurz
die idee minimap disabled weil die mich
im glaube ich ein bisschen ob ich habe
in 150
dann ernst ja ich habe jetzt eine
facetime aufnahme egal dann machen wir
ein fest in folge dann kannst du einfach
mal ein game material hochladen wir
finden eine lösung ja okay ich mache mir
immer so nein nein nein denn ich habe
jetzt vielleicht doch mal die pikmin
gehauen
logo du hast es nicht nur junge
konzentriere dich mal ein bisschen in
diesem projekt a ha
mag ich kann nicht mehr rennen ich kann
nicht mehr rennen in einer einen hohen
ein wo ich habe mich jetzt hier
eingebaut und ich habe mich jetzt noch
auf aqua nicht deine koordinaten
ich bin bei 73 47 und 41 36 73 er extra
774 ich kann jetzt die aufnahme starten
noch im nachhinein ja da machen und
irgendwann
habe ich jetzt die aufnahme an ich weiß
ich hab dem start screen beendet 674 und
wanderer ist 47 74 47
weißt du bist da drüben
du machst mich so fertig ohne wird wenn
jetzt alle auf mich haben
ja als lieb dich mal ich sehe dich nicht
hierher ich entschied mich ja heute
siehst du mich kurz ja ich sehe mich
kurz heraus ich bin jetzt immer noch
akku
ja ich höre ich höre ich höre die diako
bist du da bist du denn ich bin ich lauf
hier rum ich glaube hier um nochmal
zurück zum portal
ich versuch's ich versuche aber ich
werde ich habe keinen in der niemand
mehr stört nicht
logo ist echt immer eine qual mit dir ne
ich hab mir gesagt schlag niemals die
pikmin was macht er stellt die politik
erwartet ja weil
ich glaube die allen hinter mir her
packen musste ja die allen hinter mir
ich bin ein mann der einen seite wo ich
wo wir vor den quartz abgebaut haben ich
kann mit meinen letzten bisschen essen
gerade sehen hier sehr ich seh dich seh
ich glaube ich sehe die ich komme mir
wenn ich komme hier nicht kommt der
besucher noch den werkhof zu rennen und
dann wenn ich brauche ich mich dort
jetzt noch mit letzten schritten ein
übrigens meine aufnahme sieht man erst
jetzt weil ich bin der roboter soll ich
in die welt gehen und mich dann nur zum
dawicontrol
bei welchem punkt
bei
31 68 und 28
also iks 31 und
67 und 28 also z 28
genau wie teilen ja lass mal kurz
aufklären und zwar wird man es entweder
es kate aufnahme oder nur meine facetime
aufnahme gesehen haben weil ich während
des startbildschirms meine aufnahme
beendet da wo ich sie stoppen wieder
zusammen sind wir zusammen das schon
kräftig der touristen können wir dann in
der echten welt kräften ja auch nicht
dass der felsen ist wird ich glaube wir
sind doch die sind
ja wenigstens häufigkeit der zombie
kippenheim leute schreibt man heute
diese folge hashtag wenigstens habe ich
keinen kidman wie man hier reinkommt ich
habe mal in folge wenigstens habe ich
keine pickt man mit hashtag dann
feierlich weil das war wieder so ein
logo aktion begeistert gewesen ok dann
lasst ihr vorüber und es ist keiner auf
dem service keine sorgen machen können
hier mittendrin kräften hass und opel
haben die ganze miete gesprächen passte
table ja habe ich davor dass die waren
doch wer war das noch im felsen jetzt
gerade du kannst gar nicht machen die
kann wie haben sie denn die mitte kaputt
gemacht die kann man nirgends bauen hier
okay ich war mit einem mit einem messer
hellmann ok
alles klar hoffe ich habe nicht die zeit
haben wir noch das ist jetzt zwei
minuten bis zum überziehen dann nämlich
ist schon für mich nun ein alter mann im
mai kräftig abgesackt ich hatte ja leute
das ist einfach die beste aufnahme die
wir jemals realität was
direkt bei minecraft leute was ist los
das zählt auch jetzt wird nicht als
aufnahmen uns heute wenn wir jetzt noch
mal mein charakter kann ich nicht gerne
machen wir mal zwei minuten länger engel
das sollte sich jetzt nicht so ergangen
die hauptstadt stark start statt ich
habe in letzter zeit voll auf probleme
mit mit meinem dingsda das irgendwie ein
video hast du jetzt noch quartz
abgebauten hast jetzt noch das abgebaut
aber
nicht quarz kloster und meine ich nicht
los und ich
toll dann reicht nicht wir brauchen
nämlich wir brauchen nämlich glaubst du
wie viel
ich habe jetzt noch ein kloster und ja
aber auch mal was kannst du noch mit
quartz und der blick alles machen immer
dass da ich könnte gucken ob man hat
nehmen aber auch für alles braucht man
bloß dann für alle heute nur für alles
ja
das hab ich irgendwie nicht so
verstanden
muss ich sagen gold lage zwar haben wir
zufällig ja okay wir wissen dass wir
aber wenn nicht lassen was man hier die
erste folge beenden ja okay wir machen
die nächste folge den anschluss und
machen da die nerven fertig bist dann
leute lasst eine positive wertung da und
haut rein da